Theo hảo áng tiền Rhoi Tân, ngày 18, nguyên phân 1 bộ ngoài sau Iran để sma ở bà gãi khẳng định.
Thèeran chưa chấp họn đề xuân ngu bản sống như đưa ra, chẳng ngược với tuyên bộ chức đó của tổng thống Mỹ đô nên trang.
Ông bà gãi chưa biết, chưa có cuộc đàn phán chức tiếc nhau giữa hài bên, giù Iran đã nhận được thông diệp qua các tình trường dành.
Theo V-Ran, đề xuất mới lắm điểm của Mỹ bị đánh giá là phi thực tế, vô lý và qua đánh.
Đồng thời không phùa với lập trường của taillean.
Nội dùng để sớm đề cho lời lý quan đến các vấn đề như trường trình hạm nhăn, giã bỏ trường phạt và kìm xuất hỏi đậm tởi vì thông mốt,
trong khi đó tổng thống Mỹ đô nên trang khẳng định, thức của thảo luận đăng đạt tiến triển và trang sang Iran đã đồng ý với phần lớn nổi dông.
Hói chính tình cũng cạnh báo sẽ giá tăng xếc kế, nếu không đạt đủ thả thuận.
Giờ quan sinh định sự khá biệt chục tuyên bộ của hai bên chữa thấy tiến trình đăng phán phán phán còn nhiều trường ai,
cho bỏ cạnh xúc lâu tiếp tục theo tháng và chưa có rấu hiệu hạn nhận.